[Musique]
mais non pas voté des sanctions type le
Brésil l'Argentine le Mexique la Turquie
etc donc on imaginait que Poutine aurait
finalement un certain nombre de de sinon
d'alliés de gens qui se montreraient
compréhensibles vis-à-vis de lui mais
entre-temps les choses ont beaucoup
bougé même la Chine qui le soutien qui
continue à le soutenir mais
s'inquiète de cette guerre qui perdure
est très clairement compte la menace
nucléaire et de la jimping la redit
aujourd'hui en rencontrant Joe Biden
donc dans ce climat assez différent
Vladimir Poutine
craignait d'être très isolée alors le
prétexte c'est il y a une question
d'agenda bon évidemment personne n'y
croit c'est vrai que Vladimir Poutine a
une certaine paranoïa par rapport au
virus tout le monde se souvient de ces
espèces de stables etc mais bon là même
si d'une pink a la même paranoïa EDA
donc c'est vraiment de la part de
Poutine évitez ce qui aurait été une
humiliation parce que ça va être un G20
sans photo de famille parce que personne
ne voudrait être autour de la broche
probablement même son communiqué commun
on imagine même un texte 19 donc sans
les Russes qui
souligneraient les grands risques que
fait peser à l'économie mondiale à
l'environnement etc à la marche du monde
la continuation de la guerre en Ukraine
donc pour toutes ces raisons Poutine a
voulu éviter d'être le
canard noir de ses moutons noirs
la Russie pourtant est loin d'être
absente de ce G20 écouté en dessous la
fendeur lion pour la Commission
européenne elle répond aux questions de
Bruno Daro pour France 24
ce qui est important c'est de dire des
faits et dire que la Russie a envahi
l'Ukraine c'est un fait cette guerre a
des répercussions qui font du mal au
monde entier l'un des sujets abordés ici
c'est la sécurité alimentaire il est
important de discuter des solutions ici
pas seulement de l'accord sur les
céréales de la mer Noire mais par
exemple de faire en sorte grâce à la
solidarité que l'Ukraine puisse exporter
ses céréales vers les pays vulnérables
qui dépendent de son approvisionnement
en fait il s'adresse au désordre créé
par la Russie face au pénuries
céréalières face au choc énergétique qui
soutient encore Moscou finalement marque
en a parlé il y a eu si vous voulez une
tentative de la part de Vladimir Poutine
qui était à la fois révoltante mais
plutôt habile qui consistait à dire je
suis le la figure de proue d'un nouveau
mouvement des nonaliniens en quelque
sorte et c'était alors
la tribune de l'ONU il y a deux mois
seulement
Emmanuel Macron essayer de convaincre
c'est non alliés ils ont réussi alors le
discours de Macron consistait justement
dire vous vous trompez d'impérialisme
puisque le mouvement des non-alignés
était pour une lutte contre toute forme
d'impérialisme et là vous en avez un qui
va vous conduire qui essaie de vous
conduire alors qui reste il y a
effectivement des pays qui sont sur la
sur la tranche mais il y a une grande
partie en Afrique de pays qui continuent
à se dire si on ne ménage pas Poutine
c'est l'étranglement pour nous et là ça
fait penser à des si vous voulez à une
réflexion sur le nécessaire sur le
caractère politique et presque
pardonnez-moi du mot mais presque
anthropologique de cette guerre on ne
peut pas considérer cette guerre qui met
en jeu alors non seulement il y a le
nucléaire mais aussi toute la manière
dont on peut se représenter l'humain les
rapports de force une dictature qui veut
avoir qu'un seul rang dans le dans la
ligne de vue donc tout ça est est
profondément j'allais capital décisif et
vous avez des pays parce qu'ils n'ont
pas la possibilité d'être économiquement
indépendant ou qui ne l'ont pas fait ou
qu'ils n'ont pas choisi qui se disent on
ne peut pas se permettre à un affront
aboutir ou un conflit même verbal donc
voilà il y a ceux qui j'allais dire
encore une fois cet aspect qui avait
pris Poutine qui consistait à dire au
fond lutter contre l'Occident c'est un
nouveau mouvement des Non Alignés j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu faiplope
sauf pour certains qui sont directement
concernés par les Russes l'objet du
sommaire c'est donc notamment de faire
pression sur la Russie marque beaucoup
Paris sur la Chine a commencé par Moscou
par Paris bien sûr et Washington qui qui
compte sur sur Pékin pour faire pression
sur Moscou oui parce que toute l'idée de
la stratégie américaine et une de celle
qui a peut-être le mieux exprimé
Sherman qui est la numéro 2 du
Département d'État c'est convaincre de
plus en plus Pékin qui ont parti on est
déjà convaincu que la Russie c'est un
boulet actuellement et qu'elle est
quasiment et que avec tout ce qui est en
train de se passer
il faut justement que la Chine pour
plein sa respectabilité internationale
et joue à plein pour arrêter la guerre
pour faire pression sur la Russie pour
arrêter la guerre faire pression sur la
Russie pour que elle n'utilise pas
l'arme nucléaire et d'une certaine
manière c'est ce qui est en train de se
dessiner et ce qui va se passer au G20
ça va être une autre fracture
c'est-à-dire une fracture entre d'un
côté tous ces grands émergents y compris
la Chine est l'Inde qui disent bon ben
voilà maintenant l'urgence est à tout
prix d'arrêter la guerre il faut que les
combats cessent il faut que l'on
revienne à la normalité que les
approvisionnements céréales continuent
que le prix de l'énergie n’explose plus
etc tous ces pays qui en sont
déstabilisés ou qui ont profité
par la guerre voilà très préoccupé par
la guerre et de l'autre les occidentaux
les États-Unis en premier lieu mais
aussi les Français les Britanniques etc
qui disent bon
ce sera soi-même aux Ukrainiens de
décider quand au parachever la
reconquête du territoire ukrainien
faut créer un rapport de force et on ne
peut pas tout de suite arrêter la guerre
et c'est là-dessus paradoxalement qui
risque d'y avoir dans les discussions de
ses proies à partir de demain matin la
fracture la plus forte cette rencontre
un shibaïden en prélude à ce sommet la
perméo de dirigeants d'énumer leur
désaccords 3 heures durant au final
écouter la conclusion qu'on donne le
président américain
es entre vous et moi personnellement
mais nos gouvernement ont tellement de
choses à régler en tant que dirigeant de
nos donations nous partageons la
responsabilité à mon sens de montrer que
la Chine et les États-Unis peuvent gérer
leurs différences
empêcher que la concurrence ne devienne
un jour proche du conflit et trouver des
moyens de travailler ensemble sur les
questions mondiales
urgentes qui nécessite notre coopération
mutuelle
actuellement les relations entre la
Chine et les États-Unis sont dans une
situation telle que nous nous en
préoccupons tous beaucoup
car cela ne correspond pas aux intérêts
fondamentaux de nos deux pays et de nos
deux peuples et ce n'est pas ce que la
communauté internationale attend de nous
en tant que dirigeant des deux
principaux pays
nous devons déterminer la voie à suivre
pour les relations entre les États-Unis
et la Chine
le ton du ministre chinois des Affaires
étrangères qui rendent en compte de
cette rencontre assure que la Chine n'a
pas l'intention de prendre la place des
États-Unis ou de changer l'ordre
international existant c'est fort tout
de même il a obtenu des garanties
chinoises Joe Biden Gautier abinsky
alors attention c'est pas parce que
dubaïden est apparu regaillardi
revigorer à cause du grâce au résultat
des élections mi-mandat qu'il a obtenu
ce qu'il veut simplement au fond là où
il est habile c'est qui dit au chinois
si vous me prêtez ou nous prêter main
forte justement à propos de la Corée du
Nord ou à propos de la Russie nous on
viendra pas aussi ce qu'a dit bah il a
nous on viendra pas vous chercher des
poux dans la tête et donc Taïwan même si
on reconnaît pas le fait que ça la
théorie d'une seule Chine que ça
appartient à la Chine on peut aussi nous
américains être relativement soft sur la
question du moment que vous nous aidez
sur les choses principales et de l'autre
côté vous avez un teasing qui dit au
fond si un jour il fallait en arriver à
un conflit moi je préférerais que ça
soit moi qui qui décide et de ne pas y
être
contraint par les autres il y a si vous
voulez une approche justement d'intérêt
commun par rapport à la Chine ou à
l'Inde il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant aussi notamment l'Inde
pourquoi l'Inde se détache-t-elle de la
Russie parce que là on en arrive à un
point ou si vous voulez les certains
émergents considèrent qu'il y a dans la
démarche de Vladimir Poutine quelque
chose de suicide c'est-à-dire quelque
chose qui est prêt à bousiller
pardonnez-moi le terme l'ensemble on le
voit avec l'industrie du gaz bousiller
dépend entier de la force de la Russie
pour obtenir un résultat plus que
chimérique et hypothétique alors que
vous avez ces pays-là y compris
forcément la Chine qui se disent
attendait on est on siège sur des
potentialités sur des capacités qu'elles
soient militaires commerciales énormes
c'est pas le moment de s'aborder
l'ensemble un recul de la part de la
Chine regarde les discours quand même
très limite vindicatif qu'on avait
entendu de la part de congrès du PCCA
c'est pas un recul la Chine est
parfaitement capable de mener les deux à
la fois le 8 novembre
militaire pour rencontrer la commission
militaire centrale donc il y a d'un côté
cet aspect belliqueux et où on rappelle
clairement haut et fort que Taïwan reste
l'objectif à terme mais ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que la Chine est une vraie
puissance que n'est pas la Russie le
drame de la Russie dans cette guerre
c'est qu'elle c'est qu'elle reste un
pays qui a le PIB de l'Italie entre Sud
l'Italie et de l'Espagne donc ce n'est
pas une superpuissance d'échine lait et
surtout la Chine a du temps à la
différence de Poutine si Jean Ping est
jeune et c'est donc c'est l'idée de
voilà ça prendra le temps donc il y aura
toujours ce
cette espèce de de rapport de force
alors les Américains n'ont pas non plus
abandonné ce qu'ils appellent la ligne
confrontationnelle avec la Chine ils
continuent à penser que la Chine le seul
vrai rivale que la Chine était un rivale
systémique et que donc c'est ça l'enjeu
stratégiques centrale mais effectivement
les uns comme les autres considère que
pour le moment ça ne sert à rien de de
continuer à
ajouter de l'huile sur le feu doux cette
volonté commune de calmer le jeu dans
l'autre actualité du jour le pkka dément
tout implication dans l'attentat qui a
fait 6 morts à l'heure où nous parlons
en Turquie hier à Istanbul
l'organisation séparatiste kurde et
pourtant accusé par Ankara la police
turc qui annonce avoir été une suspecte
parce qu'il est intéressant de souligner
c'est que d'après les autorités turques
à Marc semoule il s'agit d'une syrienne
de 23 ans qui se serait infiltrant en
Turquie en passant par Afrique zone sous
contrôle des cures et commandités depuis
kobanet oui alors
disons que la rapidité dans
l'arrestation de la suspecte et le fait
que la suspecte serait tout de suite
passée aux aveux laisse un peu perplexe
ensuite on va pas faire de complotisme
mais bon voilà ensuite ça n'a rien
d'impossible que le pkka est démenti
c'est normal
d'abord le pkka sauf exception rarissime
souvent dites pas ce genre d'attentat ce
sont à chaque fois les faucons pour la
liberté du Kurdistan tac bon que l'on
peut malgré tout soupçonner de lien avec
le pkka qui revendique ce type d'action
comme l'attentat la voiture piégée près
du stade de Besiktas en 2016 qui avait
fait 47 morts donc en même temps
pourquoi un attentat maintenant parce
que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
jusqu'ici le PK
qui est organiquement lié aux forces des
enfin au curieux de syrien qui contrôle
le nord et syrien et aux forces
démocratiques syrienne a toujours évité
de lancer la moindre attaque à partir du
nord de la Syrie pour éviter de donner
un prétexte à la Turquie donc on voit
mal pourquoi il ferait ça maintenant
ensuite c'est un moment particulièrement
délicat puisque Ankara bloque l'adhésion
de la Finlande et de la Suède à l'OTAN
en disant vous devez nous donner un
certain nombre de garanties sur les
cures de réfugiés chez vous et sur le
fait que vous comprenez vous participez
à notre lutte antiterroriste donc au
moment où les choses étaient plus ou
moins en train de s'arranger etc de
nouveau boom attentat qui remonte
l'important de cette question du
terrorisme donc c'est quand même toute
cette affaire et quand même à bien des
égards très bizarres et très étrange et
très gênante et elle rappelle l'été 2015
quand
er Dean qui est en difficulté il a il
était le premier parti mais il n'avait
pas gagné de majorité à précipiter de
nouveau une reprise du pays avec les
Kurdes après des années de négociation
et ce qui lui a permis de gagner 6 mois
plus tard triomphalement les élections
pour le ministre turc de l'Intérieur le
pkka aurait cherché à brouiller les
pistes écoutées
dans une conversation téléphonique
enregistrée après l'attaque les
instructions de l'organisation
terroriste était clairement de tuer la
terrorisme il voulait la tuer pour nous
empêcher de remonter la filière et ainsi
de comprendre les raisons de l'attaque
couper Gautier ribinsky il a cherché la
Turquie cherche à un prétexte pour
envahir le nord de la Syrie faute de
pouvoir s'en prendre à la Grèce par
exemple alors si c'était le cas ça
signifierait un aveu de faiblesse
terrible ça voudrait dire que tout ce
qu'il a essayé de monter pendant disons
la deuxième la seconde partie de la
guerre j'allais dire au sens le plus
fort du terme en Syrie ça a loupé parce
que son idée c'était bien d'établir une
sorte de tampon de zone tampon entre la
Turquie et la Syrie dans laquelle il y
avait des miliciens il y avait aussi
quelques Kurdes mais des miliciens
arabes qui avaient été retournés
moyennant finance et que de cette chose
là ce montage n'aurait pas marché donc
ça voudrait dire que la Turquie n'a pas
réussi à manipuler ou du moins pas à
terme pas sur le long terme c'est c'est
combattants et que donc son projet de
zone de protection de la Turquie ne
fonctionnerait pas couper oui pourquoi
pas on s'est évidemment que le problème
de erdo c'est que même quand il a une
certaine surface à l'extérieur pour ces
démarches qu'elles soient que ça soit le
grand écart entre la Russie et l'Ukraine
ou d'autres il a toujours ce problème de
fond c'est que en Turquie la situation
économique et sociale et des gringole de
jour en jour et que cette chose-là
évidemment ce que disait Marc est tout à
l'heure il a pu le rattraper un certain
nombre de fois est-ce que ça sera de
vitamine æternam c'est pas certain donc
oui on peut on peut penser à ça mais
c'est vrai que le contexte qui était pas
trop mauvais pour la Turquie semble un
peu venir contredire cette cette
facilité de d'affirmation merci Gauthier
merci Marc Seymour c'était on va plus
loin on se retrouve dans moins de 3
minutes pour un nouveau journal dans
Paris direct avec nous
[Musique]